[Music]
foreign
you know as I mentioned before we
started recording I spoke with your
colleague there sir Roger Penrose about
uh his theory of what he calls
orchestrated uh objective reality which
involves very complex you know uh
detailed
um predictions about how wave functions
actually collapse and and they do so in
connection to another one of his great
you know kind of triumphs involves
What's called the wild curvature which
is a derivative of an analog function
within you know continuous uh three
dimensions of space and one of time in
GR
and but I wonder you know and I asked
him about his thoughts on super
intelligence and the simulation
hypothesis and and he was very not
sanguine because as you probably know he
doesn't believe the brain is a computer
in a sense and right and and
um so I wonder how is that a valid
objection in other words I say there
aren't you know the ultimate computers
aren't even quantum computers they're
they're you know well they are quantum
computers but but Consciousness is a
manifestation of a you know of of this
very very highly non-trivial classical
problem
um that uh that does involve at some
level
um you know how a wave function actually
collapses and what causes it to collapse
and then it's instantiated in terms of
these microtubules inside of the human
brain so what how would you react to
that what if these ultimate computers
that the ultimate you know simulators
will will come up with or have nothing
to do with uh with an advanced you know
MacBook Pro
yeah so I mean so I I don't buy this
claim of quantum Consciousness I don't
particularly think that Quantum
phenomena
um are uh important for how we humans
achieve our
high level cognition
um I think the human brain is basically
too noisy to really take advantage of
quantum superpositions
um
if they were right about that
then uh what the what would have to be
assumed in order for the simulation
argument still to hold would be that at
technological maturity you were able to
construct
extremely powerful quantum computers
such that
you would be able to make a lot of
simulations of mines in the future even
though each of those Minds that you
would have to simulate would require
harnessing Quantum computation I mean it
does seem like if the human mind
naturally evolved to take advantage of
those Quantum phenomena then presumably
a technological immature civilization
could also take advantage of those
phenomena and probably do it on a larger
scale or
at least with great parallelism so that
I've had to guess it would still be
feasible to
create astronomical numbers
of human-like experiences even under
those assumptions but as I said I don't
buy the assumptions
when you look at you know these kind of
arguments
um I guess you know one question that
naturally arises is yes if these if
these processes you know people tend to
put a lot onto the wall under the rug as
we say you know saying something is
quantum right so that allows for a lot
of you know either sloppy thinking or or
you know in some sense a lot of latitude
but you know thinking about processes
that are continuous versus discrete I do
note that you know Turing in his paper a
lot of people forget this he was only
talking about digital computers now that
could have been because those are the
only kinds of computer I mean analog
computers existed right I mean they've
been around for thousands of years uh
but I I don't think he was necessarily
making a distinction between quantum
computers which you know people have
thought about but um but yeah where do
they fit in I mean it seems to to me in
most cases quantum computers at least
today are the best devices ever made for
studying quantum computers
um they they can do other things and and
colleagues of yours like Scott Aronson
and others have have you know done great
work and and you know kind of
forecasting what they could do but um
but do you is is there sort of hype with
that not Drake Equation level hype but
uh is and are people basically
extrapolating from you know hearing this
magical word Quantum to this enormous
infinite power which is not really the
intention in other words is quantum you
know is a quantum computer really the
ultimate evolution uh that's necessary
in any way for to unlock the simulation
you know uh arguments
uh no no I don't think it's necessary
either for the simulation argument or
for indeed a
developing machine super intelligence
um I think if we really got quantum
computers to work they would accelerate
uh certain types of computation
um that would be useful for example as
you said for simulating Quantum systems
also for cracking certain cryptographic
codes and no doubt people would find
other uses for them
um possibly some Newsies that might be
helpful for developing artificial
general intelligence although it's not
completely clear how
um but it's not needed
um I mean in fact
if we look at the current
main types of algorithms that are used
in machine learning
they are quite
insensitive to precision and and a very
sort of digital approach seems to work
very well like initially people were
using
in a 32 or 64 bit floating numbers to
represent the parameters of these large
neural networks turns out that's
Overkill and you don't need that kind of
precision like 16-bit numbers are
perfectly fine and you can kind of
discretize things quite a lot and it
still works you save a bunch of
computing power and you don't really
lose that much in performance and
to me uh the human mind also looks like
a system which has to be robust to noise
it can't be too fuzzy about
you know the 10th decimal in some
particular setting in some neuron
because like biological systems are
noisy things wiggle around all the time
you know sometimes
you do exercise and you heat up by one
degree and then you could like yeah you
you you can't rely on on those
excessively fine gradations I think and
so that kind of forces you to use a
slightly more robust Paradigm where
exactly where you carve up the bits
doesn't really
you know it's not critical for the
functionality
so
um my wife has a question which is um if
the simulation argument is correct why
are there so many Kardashians
well
why wouldn't there be I guess it's it's
like these you know people that like
Shirley MacLean here yeah people always
think that they they have they're
reincarnated but they're always like
super interesting backstories you know
that they were the made of and Marie
Antoinette or something you know it's
never like I was one of the guys who who
put the axles on some wheel that that
ran off a donkey cart putting a pyramid
Block in place you know 2 900. anyway
um I guess it's the the bias towards um
uh towards you know kind of people
thinking of themselves with with more
importance I mean putting a kind of the
similarity bias so to speak but you know
that was just a joke really but but in
seriousness um there is but you could
ask as sort of related question right so
you could ask
is the human history that we observe
more or less interesting than you would
expect a typical history of some
human-like intelligent species to be on
some random planet for that were
human-like creatures
um
like do you think on most planets things
would just be a lot more boring or are
we sort of in the middle of the
distribution
um I mean if if I I don't know that
there is anything particularly
suspect if we just look at how things I
mean it might be kind of a little bit
surprising that life evolved at all and
stuff like that but once you get to
to the rise of homo sapiens then
you know it doesn't seem that there's
this amazing sequence of coincidences
within the past few thousand years that
are just like that looks astronomically
likely unless somebody rigged it to be
like that